[musique]
œufs il semble que tout va bien quelque chose de bien
une ville a été construite autour de l'usine, c'est-à-dire
les gens sont venus ici pour travailler à l'usine
c'est comme
2001 ils n'en valent pas la peine depuis de nombreuses années je
Je travaille pour beaucoup qui ont dit avant
qui a déjà pris sa retraite avant elle
conduit ici si blessé
a fait travailler des appartements et des revenus
était digne maintenant c'est comme ça avec ça déjà
fatigué à l'extérieur les gens courent
[musique]
plaisanté
laissez-moi être le seul qui soit de la famille
J'ai deux enfants qui travaillent si
été
femme ne travaille pas encore parce qu'elle est
congé de maternité et
il s'avère que 11 soutiens de famille dans la famille
je dois travailler pour deux
travaux
mais ce n'est toujours pas assez
dans les réalités actuelles
donc la situation n'est pas rassurante
[musique]